good humans welcome to another episode
of spectrum we do this series to
humanize people that's right and this
episode is about paparazzi absolutely
nothing but we're about to find out
enjoy the episode in my first couple of
weeks working Adam Sandler spit on me
oh and just two years before that I was
caddying for him at a golf tournament
and we were best friends I know the kid
cudi version
I know Gaga's version version I damned
that song B I know that song yeah and if
any if any paparazzi says they don't
know the lyrics at least as much as I do
where I could sing along if I hear it
and if they say they don't know it
that's a lie too because it's a song
made for us none of those guys know the
lyrics to Pavarotti
Rossi I don't mind photos being taken to
me obviously if I was in celebrity shoes
and I was cashing big checks and I was a
public figure I would probably have to
get used to it a little bit more but as
just a civilian you know I don't mind
I love being photographed only for the
fact that it's a it's memorable it's a
part of history you know you you you can
relate to something of the past by
looking at it or even nowadays you can
remember a moment so I loved I loved
that I like that answer
[Music]
I'm not gonna strongly agree with it but
nine out of ten times you know if you
take a picture of their celebrity and
they don't want you to take a picture of
them you know there'll be some sort of
rude comment that they'll that they'll
throw out there you know get a real job
something like that no I always rebut
with well you chose your job and this is
what comes with your job so we're in
this together
but I won't strongly agree with it just
because you know they don't always treat
me bad I think it depends on what you
picture them and they see you what
you're picturing for example I
photographed the Hemsworth brothers
surfing they don't mind it because they
look good surfing but if they couldn't
surf like Liev Schreiber he can't surf
at all he didn't like it when I
photographed him trying to learn how to
surf he wanted me to delete the images
he didn't like it overall I disagree for
sure
in general I've had way more positive
experiences with celebrities that I've
had negative it depends on you really
I'm trying to be nice at the end of the
day I'm trying like I got attacked by
Woody Harrelson at the airport you know
in my first couple of weeks working Adam
Sandler spit on me and just two years
before that I was caddying for him at a
golf tournament and we were best friends
I strongly disagree only because I knew
what I was getting into when I chose to
become a paparazzo the way I imagined it
at one point in my head that I was gonna
be guy I meet celebrities I take their
phone I make some money I don't take it
personal I don't think at home I do what
I do whether they woke up on the right
or wrong side of the bed that's up to
them that's their reaction I'm there to
work with them as much as they allow me
to work with them but after that it's on
them you know whatever they do and you
know you just follow the laws you follow
the rules and you work with it you never
work against it and I sleep good at
night they seem really good at night
[Music]
kind of having a pin you gotta have an
opinion
I like to say that of course I agree I
would never go into a celebrity's
bathroom or inside of someone's house or
inside of a restaurant outside on the
street walking on the beach those are
where I sell or get my photos and video
outside it's all open there's there's
two points with the whole privacy thing
number one they're a public figure okay
and if you put it on your Instagram here
a public figure there's a meaning there
and there's there's a point oh there's a
reason why they're a public figure
they're a public figure because they're
out in the public they've given up their
privacy somewhat to be a public figure
I've never shot a funeral and I never
will I think a funeral is pretty very
very private no matter what status of a
celebrity so I've been offered a lot of
money to work on funerals and I and I
will not work on a funeral shooting to a
pool and a resort from the hilltop yeah
I'll do that
people went crazy for the last shot of
Michael Jackson the guy that ran up to
Michael Jackson's gamble and shot inside
and all those guys that pushed to get
that shot you got lucky you got a lot of
money my conversation steers towards I'm
gonna take a clean photo nice fashioned
have an exchange keep it moving B I
strongly disagree that they everyone
deserves privacy now I know the laws so
I don't have to justify what I can or
cannot do because I already know better
I don't have to speak about things that
are gone off of this because I don't do
that because it's common sense
you're not even justifying it's not even
in my realm because it's public figure
public domain no privacy there
[Music]
the way I always see it the way we
talked about on our podcast is that you
know there's a lot of guys that are that
I consider I call them savages they're
just the aggressive photographers that
are always out there to to exploit
whatever they're trying to do
everybody's different some guys make us
look bad
some guys make us look a little bit
better but there is a bad and a good
side to this business what's that old
saying you can't have your state into
you yeah you're making a lot of money
you're in the public figure you're out
and about you're gonna get notice if not
by a fan you're gonna get noticed by one
of us and you're gonna get your picture
taken
if I was an a-list celebrity and I was
out and about I would make sure that I
don't take big bites on my burrito and I
would make sure that I don't pick my
nose
you know after sip of my coffee I would
just try to be proper in every which way
let me make sure I got this question
down right you're saying that my job
exploits I disagree that it exploits I'm
here to capture a moment for a mass
audience if it wasn't for the mass
audience it wouldn't sell so there would
be no point to even having me on the
streets or having let me find some kind
of a newsworthy story journalism whether
you like it or not it's journalism yeah
and I've always felt like do celebrities
day they want us to pay to go see them
on movies they want us to pay and buy
their album or you know go see them in
concert when it comes with the millions
of dollars in fame is kind of like you
were saying is people are gonna take
your photo people click constantly to
see these people walking out of a
burrito stead or I don't know going to
see a movie because that's the life they
chose and so they chose that life so I'm
just trying to feed the demand
[Music]
- Rick if you go that way it's like I'm
run over here
of course they do of course they benefit
from us they benefit from my photos they
benefit you know they got into the game
for publicity they wanted that feel when
they were going in acting school when
they were thinking about the thought
when they were dreaming when they're 12
years old 9 years old 8 years who
whatever age they dreamt about that
stardom
that's what hooks you into Hollywood
that's probably what I know that's why
I'm in it I love Hollywood so yes our
photographs give them a little more
publicity good better ugly it doesn't
matter they stay in the spotlight they
stay there they're relevant that's why
it works
I agree completely with Rick and I'm
sure everybody agrees the same thing
that our pictures benefit them by far
since the advent of Instagram I've seen
more celebrity steal my pictures to put
on their instagrams to promote their
products for free and they make tons of
money on Instagram for their products
when they post our pictures they
definitely benefit from us I'll take
good I'll take it to a different level
of that celebrities come up to me and do
setups yeah and say hey I'll be at the
park riding my bike or I'll be surfing
or I'll be between all the time I'll be
here why don't you come get an exclusive
put it out there so my name is out there
so I could get more work and it's all
about I yeah there's also that aspect
where they want to do the cleanup the
Kardashian stories get that start to die
down all of a sudden you see them come
out in groups and they start hitting all
little trendy areas one day after the
other
it's all coincidence
Kate Beckinsale well like circle Craig's
until there's enough paparazzi the
governor did she gets out in her dress
stops me then it's like oh no you got it
you got it
[Music]
it's adventurous it's fun it's exciting
dangerous I'm very proud of it because I
touch people and I bring out emotion in
people I I create something out of
nothing I'm I consider I'd never did
before but I guess I consider myself an
artist I've touched someone in life as
long as I do my best work you do my due
diligence I'm not gonna get hurt and I'm
not trying to hurt nobody I just want to
make sure that everything I put forward
in the world looks clean it looks proper
I agree I'm not on the strongly agree
part just because there are aspects of
the job that I'm not proud of doing I
feel like many pictures I've taken have
been viewed by more people than the
biggest photographers in the world
there's a way of doing this job proudly
and there's a way of not doing this job
proudly and I'm sure you contacted a lot
of people and they didn't show up here
today those are the people that don't do
the job proudly the people that would
actually stand here and get on camera
and tell you that this the way this job
really is that's a proud way of doing
the job
[Applause]
[Music]
good job we should take some kind of
grouping I never met up paparazzi before
but this is interesting because it shows
that there's like obviously good people
and like different perspectives and I'm
sure we can't just judge right away we
have a lot more of these coming for you
so comment below collaborate with us we
love hearing from you as always make
sure you subscribe follow us on
Instagram like comment and we'll see you
next time